the prime minister said there are signs
of a second wave of the virus in europe
but is this the case if you look at the
countries that are most affected in the
world you'll see it's places like brazil
the united states india and south africa
the number of new cases are continuing
to rise
and these countries haven't reached
their first peak yet
in europe many countries are beginning
to relax lockdown
and travel restrictions because the rate
of infection is decreasing
however in luxembourg rates of infection
have increased by 117.6
points in the last fortnight it's a
small country but it sits in the middle
of belgium
france and germany and it's not on the
government's list of countries to avoid
in the balkans rates are also surging
with montenegro
particularly hit hard and in spain the
rate of infection has risen
by 28.4 points that's a rise of
260 percent in the number of people
who have tested positive in the last two
weeks
one of the reasons for spain's rapid
rise in cases
is the country's northern regions rates
in aragon
are 237.9 per 100
000 people and neighboring navara and
catalonia
are also high so are these spikes a
cause
for concern here in europe we've managed
to suppress the pandemic a fair amount
in many countries
but we are seeing up surges in caseloads
in
spain in italy and and increases new
cases per day here in the uk
so there are concerns that here in
europe who may be heading towards a
second wave
it's a bit early to be sure of that yet
but these are certainly concerning
numbers that we're seeing right now
and just like in spain there are places
in the uk where the number of infections
is going up in blackburn with darwin
there has been a 98
increase in infection rates in the last
fortnight and in oldham
where some lockdown measures have been
reintroduced today the rate of infection
65.4
that's an increase of 240 percent
in the last week remember this graph
we used to see it every day at the
government's daily press briefings we
don't see it as much anymore
and the national uk picture had been
declining
although regional spikes like the ones
we just looked at mean
there is a slight increase right at the
end of the graph here
the number of cases is 300 692
up 581 since yesterday the number of
deaths reported
in the last 24 hours is 119.
so although it may be too early to know
if we are seeing
any second waves quite yet local spikes
like these are likely to continue
causing some concern